[Music]
foreign
Cecilia's the NHS is the last resort but
the Scarborough Care Home goes into the
long weekend knowing another strike
could impact residents who fall ill
there's another challenge for us in
Social care because we've been faced
with many challenges recently and not
least the pandemic but also we've had
strikes and ambulance services and the
doctors and now nurses again so we're
we're concerned to make sure that should
the need arise that we can still get the
cover required should people that we
look after be seriously ill and have to
go to hospital if necessary we will get
extra nurses in here that we have on
standby to help give the care that's
needed
members of the Royal College of Nursing
will begin a 28-hour strike on Sunday
evening walking out even as other unions
accepted a five percent pay offer from
government that even their own
leadership had recommended
well it was very clear from our members
that this payoffer that's on the table
isn't sufficient that's why they
rejected the payoffer and regardless of
whether it's paid or not come Tuesday
our members position remains I have
every trust and confidence in our
members that they will do the right
thing and that is that they will not
accept it they do not believe it sorts
out the retention and recruitment issues
within our profession the strikes have
left hospitals scrambling to prepare
with 10 of the largest teaching trusts
and the world famous Great Ormond Street
Children's Hospital warning that
standards of care could be affected this
is one of many hospitals struggling to
safely staff all its services this
weekend but NHS leaders are hopeful this
may be the last of the industrial action
on Tuesday the NHS staff Council
representing all unions will vote on
mass on the government's pay deal with
the expectation it will be approved we
hope that if the staff Council accepts
this then all the unions will accept it
but I think it's really important to say
that that doesn't mean that we as
leaders of the Health Service don't
recognize the real concerns amongst
staff that their pay has fallen the
issues that lie behind the strike issues
of recruitment of retention and
motivation they will continue to be
there and we need to address those
questions the six-month dispute may be
close to a conclusion but having won a
below inflation pay rise the challenges
for NHS staff will remain Paul Kelso Sky
News